there's one view the airplane Indiana  pilot Matt lehtinen says he's lucky to  be alive after his plane crash-landed  onto a Canadian mountainside the father  of two recorded everything he did to  survive I mean the middle of Quebec  trying to get my SOS to work Lenin was  flying to Quebec City about two weeks  ago when the planes engine suddenly lost  power leaving him stranded in thick  forests with help miles from the crash  site  I came two inches from being impaled by  a tree actually my shorts lehtinen  suffered only minor cuts and scrapes  from the incident as fuel leaked from  the wings he rushed back into the plane  for supplies despite the possibility of  an explosion lehtinen was able to send  his coordinates to rescue crews he also  started a fire using fire sticks a  lighter and moss to create a smoke  signal your helicopter helicopter  absolutely crazy there yeah we'll be  right back you're watching CBS this  morning Saturday